so if this bar right over here
represents one hole so the whole thing
is shaded in with the purple color my
question to you is which of these other
bars and it might be more than one of
them represent one half so our goal our
goal is to see one half is to see one
half so once again like always pause the
video and try it on your own okay so
you've tried it on your own let's work
through it so if we're thinking about
halves so and we just have one of them
so let me just try to draw another
another bar here it would look something
like this I'll try to draw it pretty
close to these other bars here so I
would ride it into two equal sections so
two equal sections and I would only care
or I would be really fill in one of them
that would be one half of this figure
and actually these sections don't look
quite equal and it looks it looks a
little bit off and it's pretty good I
think you get the idea these that my
intent is to draw these two have equal
to be equal so then this right over here
would be one half now none of these are
divided into halves this one over here
is divided into into fourths
this one over here is divided into one
two three four five so it's divided into
fifths this is divided into one two
three four five six so it's divided into
sixths this is divided into thirds so
we're going to have to really relate one
half to other two to two breaking up
your whole into different amounts not
just breaking it up into two equal
sections breaking it up into four equal
sections five equal sections six equal
sections and three equal sections how do
we do that well the easiest thing might
be to just break this one up into four
equal sections you break this up into
four equal sections that's just taking
each of these two and then breaking
those up into two so that's one equal
section and another let me use that blue
color actually because that's my so
that's an equal section right over here
and this is an equal section so this is
the same thing as 1/2 notice I didn't
change
which I shaded in I just divide it into
more sections so we see that one half is
the exact same thing as two out of four
as two out of four
well how many do we have right over here
we have one two out of four so this is
one two out of four and this is one two
out of four so two fourths and one half
are the same these two are equivalent
now just might not be obvious but if you
took this block right over here and if
you were to move this one over and so
this one is painted in this one isn't
then they would look the same so that
maybe that would help to see that this
also has one half of the block of the
block filled in so this one is
definitely half now let's think about
fifths let's think about fifths so let
me so let me well there's two ways I
could do it so let me draw let me draw
fifths and this this right over here is
three-fifths and white as well just
write it down this is 3/5 this is three
sixths and this is one-third but let me
say let me draw let me draw a 3/5 right
below this let me draw so I keep wanting
to change the color um I'm using a new
arch tool and color changing isn't
coming is naturally as my old one so
this right over here so let me draw it
it let me divide it into fifths the best
I can so one two three four five and we
assume that these are equal sections I
know my drawing is imperfect but if we
have three fifths where we're going to
get two we're going to get to one two
three and one way to think about this
what I just drew is just a rearrangement
of this I just took the three filled in
sections and put them all to the left so
I have one two three and when you look
at it this way it's clear that 3/5 is
more than one half if we were to four to
try to put the 3/5 onto this one right
over here it would get us about this far
so 3/5 would go all the way over there
so 3/5 is definitely not the same thing
as 1/2 now what about three sixths three
sixths so let's think about that a
little bit can we can we take
let me draw let me draw another one of
these things I have to keep drawing over
and over again so we already know we
already know that if I split this into
two equal pieces I shade in one of them
that's one half this right over here is
one half
now can I turn this into sixths well if
I take each of these two and I split
them into three equal pieces then I'm
gonna have two times six pieces so I'm
going to have sixths so let me do that
so let me use my blue color so there you
go and then there you go I took each of
the two and split them into three and
now I have six pieces
now I haven't changed how much I've
shaded in I've now but when I think it
was one half of the entire bar but now
when I think in terms of sixths it's one
two three six three six is the exact
same thing as one half we have one two
three six and once again if you took
these two when you shifted them over
here you would get something that looks
very much like that or like this so this
right over here is the same thing as 1/2
now what about one-third one-third all
right I think you see where this is
going and always you should just feel
free to pause the video and try to work
it on your own or frankly if you get
what's going on in the video you don't
have to watch it okay all right so let's
divide it into thirds let's divide it
two thirds and we're talking about
one-third we're talking about we are
talking about one-third right over here
and very clearly you see you see that
one-third is less than three six and
three six is the same thing as one half
one half would take you about this far
would take you about one will take you
that far one-third is less than that so
one-third is not equal to one-half
hopefully you found that fun